bonjour à toutes et à tous et paléo news
l'émission qui fait les news avec du
vieux alors le petit dernier paléo news
avant la fin de l'année avant la fin de
l'année 2021 et si vous êtes sur les
réseaux sociaux ou que vous êtes à paléo
artistes vous n'avez pas pu manquer
cette nouvelle reconstruction de l asmo
terium et l'asmo terium qui est connu
pour être j'ai envie de dire la licorne
préhistorique donc c'est un rhinocéros
unicornes et bien si vous avez suivi un
peu les actualités vous avez
certainement vu passer cette nouvelle
reconstruction ou la grande corne d
l'asmo terium est remplacé par cette
espèce de bosses en fait donc boss qui
recouvre à peine en fait la grosse la
grosse cheville osseuse qui se trouve au
sommet du crâne des l'asmo terium alors
par comparaison avec les autres
rhinocéros
on s'était dit que ça devait être une
grande corne mais donc il ya un nouvel
article qui propose qu'en fait c'était
pas une grande corne mais simplement une
petite bosse de kératine par dessus
alors d'où ça vient cette information
est bien ça bien de cet article sortie
d'un riche journal of thériault logis
que vous ne devez pas connaître et que
je ne connaissais pas avant cela mais
bon apparemment chez un journal qui est
peer review v comme les autres agents
vivent bien
et qui a été écrit par un chercheur
russe du nom de titoff et ses collègues
alors qu'est ce que ça vaut cette
nouvelle reconstruction de paléo de et
l'asmo terium pardon à c'est une
question délicate c'est une question
délicate parce que cet article il a il a
plusieurs défauts quand même il a
plusieurs défauts déjà premièrement il
est mal écrit il est très très mal écrit
l'an l'anglais n'est pas bon du tout on
voit bien que le la personne qui l'a
écrit qui est probablement titoff
lui-même
ne parlez pas bien anglais écrivait
n'écrivez pas bien l'anglais mais du
coup ça donne un espèce de sentiment de
logements foutisme à cet article qui est
pas qui
ne sert pas sa cause alors je dis pas
qu'il faut savoir parler parfaitement
anglais etc moi même je suis je parle
anglais comme une vache espagnole comme
vous avez pu le constater
si vous suivez notamment ma chaîne
secondaire mais il faut il faut bien
voir que les articles ils sont donc
écrit par un voire plusieurs
scientifiques donc ils sont censés être
lu et relu qu ils sont ensuite relu par
les
pairs durant le processus de peer review
et ils sont aussi relu par les éditeurs
qui vont ensuite les publier que donc
dans tout ce monde là et quand même
censé y avoir au bout d'un moment un
certain soin apporté à l'écriture de
l'arctique et au moins une de ces
personnes qui à un moment ils censés se
dire non mais là c'est pas possible on
peut pas publier sa requête dans cet
état là ce n'est pas arrivé avec cet
article dont il ya eu un certain je m'en
foutisme ça donne un petit sentiment on
va dire ça veut pas dire qu'il ya eu je
m'en foutisme ça donne un petit
sentiment de weather regarder ça et se
sont dit que c'était bien quoi donc ça
déjà sur la forme c'est pas terrible
maintenant la question c'est le fond on
va pas ce trop s'intéresser quand même à
la forme la grande question c'est le
fond est ce que sur le fond cet article
se défend bon bah d'où elle vient cette
nouvelle reconstruction du de la corne d
l'asmo terium comme ça en fait tout
juste une toute petite bosse de kératine
par dessus la cheville osseuse sans ses
soucis et pourtant gigantesque bon bah
ça vient en fait de d'une comparaison
avec les données d'un autre chercheur
qui s'appelle hieronimus donc aironi mus
qui est citée par ici voilà là
donc ironie mus il a étudié les ceyrat
obtient et sur les ceratops hier en fait
il a comparé la texture de los ché les
ceyrat obtient avec plein d'autres
espèces modernes dont des espèces pour
lesquelles on sait ce à quoi cette
texture osseuse est rattachée afin de
reconstituer en faite le les cornes et
les toutes les ornementations qui lie à
sur le crâne des cératopsidés donc quand
il y avait une surface rugueuse à quoi
ça correspond chez une espèce moderne
quand il y avait une surface quadrillé
parce que des fois ça arrive qu'on ait
des genres de quadrillage sur l'os à
quoi ça correspond chez une espèce
moderne quand on a une surface qui est
plein de petits trous à quoi ça
correspond chez les espèces modernes
donc les sénatoriales ils ont tout ça
ils ont tout un tas de textures osseuse
sur leurs crânes qui correspondent à
autant de tissus mous qui ne se sont pas
préservés donc ça peut être des écailles
ça peut être de la kératine ça peut être
juste de la police par exemple
et donc ironie mus il a fait un grand
catalogue il est très très c'est
vraiment très complet très très long
très très très bon article erdimi
s'étale 2009 il a fait un grand
catalogue de toutes ces textures osseuse
et à quoi elles correspondent chez les
espèces modernes et si dans cet article
titov avait fait ça la même chose ben
j'aurais on va dire que j'aurais été
peut-être un peu plus convaincu le
problème c'est que l'analyse de titov
elle cite rapidement ironie musset
talent et conclue très vite que abbas
est juste quelques rugosité avec
quelques tissus
voyez ici quelques vaisseaux sanguins et
ça dans l'ironie bus ça veut dire qu'il
ya juste un petit peu de kératine dessus
point à la ligne voyez là là ça commence
ça commence à ce paragraphe ci et ça se
termine donc il ya une page avec une
grosse image voilà et ça se termine par
la voilà là maintenant il parle du prêt
maxillaire donc ça n'a plus rien à voir
avec la corne donc ça se termine ici
donc on est ça laisse un peu sur sa faim
la discussion elle est un peu short quoi
on va dire donc d'une part l'analyse
n'est pas très poussé voilà c'est juste
ça je veux dire l'analyse n'est pas très
très poussée
c'est très superficiel et puis il se
base aussi sur le fait que la corne en
fait à l'intérieur de la corde c'est
creux et il dit pas si c'était creux du
cou il pouvait pas y avoir de de poids
par dessus le problème c'est que ça on
sait que c'est pas un argument valable
parce que tout simplement tous les
animaux enfin tous les mammifères
modernes avec des cornes ou presque ont
de toute façon des des sinus aux
endroits où ils ont des cornes par
exemple tous les ruminants les ruminants
tous leurs cornes sont complètement
creuses et il ya des ruminants qui ont
des cornes exceptionnellement grandi en
a eu notamment par le passé comme pedro
vi qui avait cinq mètres de cornes une
envergure de 5 m de cornes vous avez
mégalo seros mégalo c'est ross c'est
pareil c'est le grand cerf le grand
cervidé du nord de l'europe de la
période glaciaire
mégalo ce héros s'il avait des bois
absolument gigantesque que tout ça
c'était soutenue sur un crâne et le
crâne il apparaît il avait des sinus
enfin les pariétaux les eaux pariétaux
était est et croque quoi donc tous et la
plupart des animaux qui ont des cornes
aujourd'hui et même les rhinocéros ont
des sinus en dessous de leurs cornes et
pourtant ça marche très bien ça marche
très bien pourquoi parce que vous avez
c'est petit
cette texture alvéolé en fait qui
optimise le poids et la solidité donc
c'est pas un argument valide je pense
cette ses sinus ne sont pas un argument
valide pour dire qu'il y avait pas de
cornes une grande corne du mois et
l'analyse de surface de cette espèce de
bosses ses parts à y aller elle est trop
superficiel en réalité pour réellement
soutenir que la corne d l'asmo terium
était aussi petit j'aurais bien aimé
voir en fait dans cet article des
d'autres éléments qui sont plus
directement en lien avec la présence de
la corne notamment les muscles de la
nuque parce que si vous avez une énorme
cornes sur la tête bah vous vous
attendez à avoir des énormes muscles sur
la nuque c'est ce qui est expliqué dans
cet autre article alors celui là il date
de 2005 et je pense qu'un des meilleurs
articles que j'ai pu trouver sur et
l'asmo terium
et justement on y voit une belle
reconstruit enfin une des belles images
du crâne et notamment cette vue de
l'arrière du crâne ou on voit ici cette
espèce de fausse donc ça c'est pour le
ligament du cal est ici vous avez les
muscles du cou vous voyez que les
muscles du cou sont tellement développé
que ça fait genre comme deux antennes
relais pour que les muscles une surface
d'across gigantesque ça on ne va pas
chez les rhinocéros moderne et
rhinocéros modernes ils ont juste une
surface arrière du crâne qui est concave
comme ça et cette surface conques avec
certes d'insertion aux ligaments et eau
et aux muscles donc ça elle est un peu
limité finalement à cette partie là quoi
vous n'avez pas ces deux espèces de
protubérances de chaque côté en tout cas
elles sont elles sont pas aussi
développée donc là vous avez ces deux
antennes qui certes à la croche de
muscles extrêmement puissant et ça ça
veut dire bien que la tête était très
lourde et c'est pas le cerveau qui pèse
lourd chez les rhinocéros 1 c'est
évidemment la corne donc là ça ça va
dans le sens d'une corne très très
lourde avec aussi ses épines neural sûr
qu'ils sont justement l'autre l'autre
extrémité finalement d'attache de ces
mêmes muscles ses épinards elles sont
deux fois plus haute que chez les
rhinocéros moderne donc on a des épines
neural très hautes et des surfaces
d'insertion pour les muscles du cou à
l'arrière du crâne qui sont tous les
deux indicateurs qui la tête peser très
lourd alors ça peut être à cause des
dents et de la masse de la tête elle
même puisque la tête des l'asmo terium
est gigantesque même comparé un
rhinocéros mais enfin ça donne quand
même ça donne quand même à penser qu'il
y avait plus que ça
donc ça j'aurais bien aimé que ce soit
discutée notamment j'aurais bien aimé
qu'on discute de la puissance de ses
muscles en comparaison au poids de la
tête et que ça et que ça permette
justement d'estimer si la puissance de
ses muscles
étaient
proportionnelles juste au coin de la
tête ou bien est-ce qu'ils étaient trop
puissants et que du coup ça voulait dire
qu'il y avait quelque chose en plus que
le poids de la tête à savoir la corne
j'aurais bien aimé voir une discussion
aussi d'autres éléments sur la
la présence ou non de la corne comme par
exemple ici cet impact voyez qui est
situé ici sur le dôme de la tête cet
impact vous voyez que les bords sont
cicatrisées c'est à dire que c'est
arrivé du vivant de l'animal or un
impact comme ça sur le sommet du dôme
d'année l'asmo terium ça veut dire qu'il
y avait pas grand chose n'avait pas
grand chose sur le caillou là donc ça ça
allait dans le sens si vous voulez de
juste d'une petite couverture de
kératine exactement comme titeuf le
propose ça c'était un argument très fort
dans le sens d'une petite couverture de
kératine bon après on peut aussi
l'interpréter dans le sens opposé qui l
accord n'était très longue et très
pointu et 2 et l'asmo terium se sont
battus et du coup la corde très pointue
de son adversaire est rentré dans sa
corde à lui en bas ça se discute mais il
y aurait fallu encore faut-il le
discuter quoi donc ça ça aurait été
quand même très intéressant de d'en
parler et ça aurait été intéressant
aussi de parler au niveau des l'asmo
terium de toutes les possibles de toutes
les possibles peintures rupestres qui
ont été faites des l'asmo terrière vous
voyez qu'il ya certaines peintures
rupestres qui ont été attribués avec
l'asmo terium notamment bas en france à
rouffignac vous avez cette peinture ci
qui est un rhinocéros qui n'a qu'une
seule corne alors que les rhinocéros
laineux en avait deux donc ça ça donne à
penser que ça pourrait être un mais là
ce n'était rien et puis en russie aussi
vous avez
enfin je sais pas si c'est en russie ça
s'appelle h ou le gan tâche voilà dans
la grotte dans la grotte capot va ya
alors je ne suis pas complètement sûrs
d'eux où se trouve la grotte campo baiia
pour être tout à fait honnête mais ça
doit être en ex urss sont moins puisque
de toute façon c'est l'ère de
répartition de l'asmo terium donc
l'appareil on a des peintures avec des
rhinocéros à une seule corne alors et
dans cet article de 2005 qu'ils en
parlent mais pas dans la nouvelle
reconstruction vous voyez pas dans cette
dans ce nouvel article par titoff donc
ça ça aurait été intéressant quand même
d'en discuter bon de toute façon que ce
soit celui là où la peinture de la
grotte de rouffignac les deux sont trop
jeunes pour être véritablement d ela ce
matériel puisque les deux sont à peu
près si je me trompe pas à quinze mille
ans et l'asmo terium a disparu il ya 40
mille ans donc
très peu de chances que ce sont hélas
matériel surtout celui-là parce que il
n'ya jamais eu d l'asmo période en
france il ya eu des et l'asmo terry
n'est
mêlé l'asmo terium était à peu près le
seul et l'asmo terrines et avec sino
terium qui avait une seule et unique
cornes sur le sur le toit crânien les
autres et l'asmo terrines et avait une
corde mais sur le museau comme des
rhinocéros normaux donc il ya très peu
de chance quand même c'est il ya plus de
chances que ce soit à rhinocéros laineux
raté c'est à dire un rhinocéros laineux
qui a pas deux cornes plutôt qu'à un
plutôt qu'un et l'asmo terium en tout
cas à quinze mille ans en france il n'y
avait pas d l'asmo terre depuis plus dé
l'asmo terrienne déjà depuis longtemps
même en ex urss
en russie quoi et il n'y avait pas non
plus de l'asmo terium à quinze mille ans
et donc à la grotte de capot va ya là
c'est pareil on a ces rhinocéros à une
seule corde mais le problème c'est qu'on
est en asie et en asie il ya des
rhinocéros à une seule corde au delà
apparaît l'asmo terium je veux dire il
ya des rhinocéros en asie et ils n'ont
qu'une seule corne de rhinocéros indien
voilà c'est un rhinocéros asiatiques à
une seule corde donc on n'est pas sûr
non plus que ce soit et l'asmo terium
d'autant que encore une fois cette
peinture rupestre à quinze mille ans
donc et là en plus la cornée tout petit
donc ça ça en plus ça aurait pu soutenir
quand même le modèle de l'est l'asmo
terium à petites cornes au lieu du
modèle de l'asmo thalamas grandes cornes
mais encore faudrait-il que titov nous
en parler titov ne nous entendent pas
c'est dommage c'est dommage je pense
qu'il y avait il y avait une vraie
discussion à avoir en fait et titov
passe un peu à côté quoi il faut aussi
rappeler et c'est ce que fait aussi cet
article de 2005 que et l'asmo terium
avec juste une bosse sur le front ces
panneaux plus spécialement nouveaux
voiliers cette reconstitution là elle
date de 1934 et on y voit bien et l'asmo
terium avec exactement la même la même
morphologie que ce que titoff nous
propose donc l'idée de titoff elle même
n'est pas non plus particulièrement
nouvelle bon en tout cas voilà si vous
n'êtes pas les aux artistes c'est quand
même une proposition donc qui existe qui
existent même depuis longtemps et que
vous pouvez prendre en compte ou pas
selon votre selon votre sensibilité
il ya le pour et le contre et mais
j'aurais quand même aimé que ce nouvel
article prennent plus en compte le pour
et le contre que juste proposer une
réinterprétation des données de l'ironie
musée talent
appliquée et l'asmo terium c'est un
petit peu trop superficielle quoi
suivant nous restons avec les mammifères
mais cette fois en bouche vers d'autres
d'autres pachydermes j'ai envie de dire
nos bouchons du côté des éléphants avec
nos tuyaux mastondonte et cette nouvelle
analyse donc qui nous propose une
analyse une analyse de l'adn ancien de
nos tuyaux mastodonte c'est une analyse
en fait qu'ils se faire en réponse à un
autre article que je vais vous parler
d'abord je crois que j'en ai déjà parlé
dans paléo news mais je ne suis pas sûr
en tout cas je l'avais abordée si je les
aborder cette façon trop superficielle
pour réellement pour réellement ne pas
proposer une
représentation aujourd'hui encore une
fois donc c'était un article qui avait
analysé quelques protéines du collagène
extrait de temps probablement je pense
que c'était des dents de dengue ont fait
taire qui s'appelle no piot mastodonte
alors légaux font taire ce sont des
éléphants this ce sont des éléphants
team orf des proches parents donc des
éléphants et des mammouths qui ont vécu
en amérique du sud et je crois que
c'était au pliocène donc c'est parmi les
rares on va dire et proches parents des
éléphants qui ont vécu en amérique du
sud ont déjà un choc d'apprendre qu'il y
avait des éléphants en amérique du sud
il y en avait ne tuons mastodonte en
fait partie il ya cuvier rhône us aussi
et dans ce qu'il ya d'intéressant c'est
que l'on analyse en analysant leur adn
ils se sont rendus compte enfin en
analysant leurs protéines pardon le
collagène ce premier article ici publié
en 2019 avait trouvé que l'on veut que
second faux terre senotier au mastodonte
était proche parent du mammouth
nord-américain alors le mammouth
nord-américain c'est ce qu'on appelle
aussi le mastodonte nord américain ce
n'est pas le mammouth le mammouth il est
là c'est mamoutou ce prix me gêne us
alors que le mammouth le mastodonte
américain c'est ma mute american home
donc il faut pas les confondre les deux
donc maintenant je dirais mammouth pour
le mastodonte américain et mammuth pour
le vrai mammouth enfin les vrais mahmoud
puisqu'il ya pas qu un mammouth mais
bref donc là il avait trouvé que nos
tuyaux mastodonte était proche parent du
mammouth alors ce qui géographiquement a
du sens puisque nos tuyaux mastodonte
vivaient en amérique du sud mais mute
vivaient en amérique du nord les deux au
pléistocène
donc a priori il n'y a pas de le dire il
n'y a pas de raison de douter de sa sauf
que comme nos tuyaux mastodonte fait
partie de la grande famille très pas
monofil éthique dégonfle terre bon il
fait partie des confrères l'écho feu
terre normalement ils sont pas censés
être cousin du mam utiles sont censés
être cousins des éléphantes idée à
savoir des éléphants moderne et du
mammouth donc normalement note au
mastodonte au lieu d'aller se brancher
ici il aurait dû aller se brancher là et
ça du coup quand on a regardé le
collagène ça un peu foutu le cul par
terre de nos chercheurs qui se sont dit
oh oh parce que là si vous voulez nos
tuyaux mastodonte en lui même c'est pas
un problème c'est pas le problème
d'avoir noté au mastodonte plus proche
du mammouth ou dumas but le problème
c'est que nos tuyaux mastodonte est un
gouffre aux terres que des gros faut
taire il en existe des centaines
d'espèces et que si on commence à
trouver que nos tuyaux mastodonte est en
fait plus proche du mammouth ça veut
dire que tout le reste est faux que ce
que toute notre classification des
gaufres terre est à [ __ ] par terre et
ça ça c'est un gros problème parce que
ça veut dire qu'en gros tout ce qui se
passe pendant l'oligocène et mieux scène
au niveau des éléphants timor du coup
c'est à [ __ ] à la poubelle on croyait
qu'on comprenait en fait on comprenait
rien
donc donc ça a été quand même un choc en
2019 quand c'est sorti
et du coup ils ont enfin d'autres
chercheurs ont essayé du coup de
rapporter de nouvelles de nouveaux
éléments à 7
à cette discussion parce que c'est quand
même c'est quand même c'est quand même
perturbé je veux dire d'avoir de se
rendre compte enfin du moins de supposer
que on a tout faux donc il n'ya pas si
longtemps que ça il ya tellement peu
longtemps d'ailleurs que l'article vous
voyez n'est même pas encore mis en page
c'est toujours sous la forme de
manuscrits
là c'est toujours sous la forme de
brouillon presque c'est l'article le
contenu sera le même qu'en l'article
sera publié c'est juste que c'est pas
mis en forme c'est tout donc ils ont
analysé plus de données d'une auto
mastodonte et ils ont notamment analysé
de l'adn donc pas seulement du collagène
mais aussi de l'adn ancien donc ils ont
réussi à extraire de l'adn ancien d'une
dent d'un outil au mastodonte les toutes
les images sont à la fin donc voici la
dent en question
morphologie gonfo terre typique a envoyé
3 nov comme c'est très typique des conf
au tertre îlots fo dont tu sais ce que
veut dire tri lofo dont 3,9 et donc en
analysant cet adn et bien eux ils
trouvent et en en faisant ce qu'ils
appellent une totale évident c'est à
dire toutes les preuves morphologiques
protéomique et adn en mettant ça tous
ensemble et en faisant tourner une
analyse il trouve que nos tuyaux
mastodonte et cousins des éléphantes
idées et ne se branchent pas avec le
même but nord américain
l'honneur est sauf j'ai envie de dire
en reprenant plus de données en y
ajoutant l'adn il retrouve la position
classique de nos tuyaux mastodonte du
côté des éléphantes idée là où l'ego
faut taire sont censés être donc les
kung fu terre maintenant ça va on les
remet là où ils sont censés être few on
est sauvé toujours les mammifères
maintenant en fait on va faire les andes
au terme en général voilà les andes au
terme en général avec cette nouvelle
cette nouvelle hypothèse j'ai envie de
dire et alors là pour le coup on a du
travail qui va vraiment secoué qui va
botter des fesses et secouer des arbres
c'est à c'est une nouvelle analyse en
fait qui propose enfin une nouvelle
analyse une nouvelle article qui propose
une nouvelle hypothèse sur l'évolution
de l'ordo termine dow termine c'est le
sang chaud globalement donc le
métabolisme à sang chaud
cet article et propose que landau terme
y ait en fait n'est pas une innovation
c'est en fait un caractère primitif et à
caractère qui serait primitif à tous les
âmes note à savoir l'ancêtre en commun
des reptiles et des mammifères donc les
reptiles au sens large j'inclus les
oiseaux nocence soro psid cette nouvelle
hypothèse elle est proposée par rogers
simorre donc rogers si moore qui était
déjà connu pour avoir justement proposé
l'hypothèse que les crocodiles modernes
qui sont à sang froid n'était pas
originellement à sang froid qu'ils ont
évolué vers un métabolisme à sang froid
donc originellement les crocodiliens
était à sang chaud et sont ensuite
devenus à sang froid par une adaptation
au milieu au mode de vie aquatique me de
vie aquatique qui n'était pas leur mode
de vie original donc ces crocodiles se
sont adaptés à un mode de vie aquatique
et avec ça est venu un métabolisme à
sang froid puisque dans l'eau où il fait
relativement froid on perd beaucoup plus
vite sa chaleur dans l'eau même si l'eau
est chaude en réalité on perd plus vite
sa chaleur dans l'eau c'est un milieu
très conducteur et du coup les
crocodiliens au lieu de faire comme les
cétacés et d'avoir une couche de graisse
qui empêche de perdre la chaleur ils ont
opté pour une autre solution qui est bon
je vais arrêter de produire de la
chaleur comme ça je vais arrêter de me
refroidir dans l'eau bons appuis c'est
gagnant quand j'ai envie de dire ça
marche quand même donc rojas émouvant
c'est lui qui avait proposé cette
hypothèse est donc il a construit par
dessus cette hypothèse en tout cas lui
et son équipe que vous voyez la liste là
on construit par dessus cette hypothèse
et propose maintenant l'hypothèse encore
plus osés j'ai envie de dire encore plus
élaborée de dire qu'en fait ce sont tous
les âmes notes qui sont qui était à la
base en d'autres termes c'est à dire à
sang chaud et que les bases certains
reptiles donc les lézards les crocodiles
sont devenus ectothermes ensuite donc en
fait c'est la condition ectothermes
c'est la condition à sang froid qui
serait évolué et c'est la condition en
d'autres termes qui serait primitive
donc ça c'est ce qu'il propose dans cet
article est paru dans biology calories
donc j'ai une grosse revue quand même
c'est quand même quelque chose qui est
reconnue qui est connue et reconnue dans
la communauté scientifique alors
maintenant sur quoi se base cette cette
nouvelle hypothèse eh bien elles se
basent déjà il faut savoir d'où vient
l'hypothèse que c'est l'état métabolique
à sang chaud qui est dérivé donc qui est
de la condition évolué elle vient du
fait que les mammifères et les oiseaux
sont les seuls groupes aujourd'hui qui
sont à sang chaud tout le reste des amis
hôtes sont à sang froid tout le reste
des tétrapodes même sort à sang-froid
les amphibiens sont à sang froid les
lézards 63 les serpents sont à
sang-froid l'espé nos dons sera sans
froid les tortues sont à sang froid des
crocodiles donc il ya vraiment que les
oiseaux et les mammifères qui sont à
sang chaud donc déjà la condition
métabolique à son show elle est plus
rare que la condition métabolique à sang
froid donc ça semble être celle qui est
apparu le plus récemment dans le nombre
de groupes plus restreints et ensuite
cette condition métaboliques
chez les mammifères on a toujours pensé
qu'elle était due à l'évolution d'un
tissu qui s'appelle le tissu adipeux
brun donc ce tissu adipeux brun serait
responsable de la production de la
chaleur chez les mammifères alors que
chez les oiseaux cette condition
métabolique serait dû à une activité
musculaire mais qui serait ni de
l'effort ni du frisson c'est ce qu'on
appelle la thermogénèse sans frisson
chez les oiseaux donc c'est les muscles
qui produisent de la chaleur mais sans
se contracter et sans frissonner en fait
donc le fait qu'on ait que deux groupes
damien ott les oiseaux les mammifères
avec chacun sa propre manière de faire
de l'ordo thermie bassin suggère très
fortement qu'il y a eu deux événements
d'évolution des taux thermie indépendant
hélas ce que nous dit en fait l'équipe
de seymour sais que c'est pas si simple
c'est pas si simple les mammifères en
fait il y en a que très très peu jusqu'à
présent chez qui on a retrouvé du tissu
adipeux brun tous les mammifères n'ont
pas de tissu adipeux brun en fait il ya
que certains place à placentaire qui ont
du tissu adipeux bras les mots notres m
et les marsupiaux dans non pas par
exemple pourtant ils sont en d'autres
termes avec un métabolisme un peu
différent notamment pour les notre m
mais je veux dire ils sont considérés
comme en d'autres termes et d'un autre
côté bas chez les mammifères on a aussi
de la thermogénèse sans frissons à
savoir qu'ils utilisent le même
mécanisme que les oiseaux et ça du coup
c'est la première étape vers 10 donc si
on a de la thermogénèse sans frisson
chez les oiseaux et qu'on a de la
thermogénèse sans frisson chez les
mammifères est-ce que la thermogénèse
sans frisson ne serait pas un caractère
ancestral chez tous les amiotte d'où
l'idée ait eu du coup ce qu'ils
proposent c'est que bat tout le monde
était en d'autres termes à la base tous
les amis note était en d'autres termes à
la base
et c'est là qu'on va pas être d'accord
c'est là qu'on veut pas être d'accord
avec avec cet article parce que tout ce
qu'il recherche c'est d'arriver à
expliquer comment la thermogénèse sans
frisson étaient présents chez l'ancêtre
en commun de tout le monde de tous les
deux tout les amis note alors déjà ça se
base sur l'hypothèse que cette
thermogénèse sans frisson est ancestrale
à tout le monde ce qui n'est pas
forcément gagné puisque finalement on a
repéré deux thermogénèse sans frisson
chez personne d'autre que chez les
mammifères et les oiseaux pour l'instant
c'est peut-être aussi parce qu'on en a
pas cherché vu que pour nous tout le
reste était était en ectothermes mais
bon c'est vrai qu'il ya par exemple y
aller les boas qui produisent leur
propre chaleur notamment pendant la dent
la couvaison d e.on à l'été guy aussi
qui produisent de la chaleur donc ce
sont aussi des reptiles donc il ya quand
même quelques reptiles qui sont capables
de générer leur propre chaleur dont les
boas s'est définitivement du frisson
c'est à dire c'est les muscles qui se
contracte
et ça génère de la chaleur mais mais
c'est vrai que finalement il y aurait
des éléments qui pourraient dire
effectivement que c'est ancestrale mais
c'est pas la seule explication
déjà le problème c'est que d'une part il
faut partir du principe que cette
thermogénèse sans frisson est ancestrale
mais même une fois qu on dit qu'elle est
ancestrale il ya plein d'explications
pour dire comment cette thermogénèse
sans frisson pourrait être ancestrale à
tous les amis hot et lando termine car
landau thermie généralisée mais loin
d'être la seule explication je veux dire
la thermogénèse s'enfuit sa chair ça
sert à générer de la chaleur ok mais la
chaleur ça peut servir à plein de trucs
donc ça peut servir à couver les oeufs
ça peut servir à réchauffer un organe en
particulier pendant une période
particulière de l'année au hasard la
reproduction voilà réchauffer les
organes génitaux pendant la reproduction
ça peut servir d'adaptation à des hivers
rudes notamment quand on pense que les
amniotes ont évolué au carbonifère le
carbonifère c'est une immense période
glaciaire donc le dire ça aurait pu
servir à survivre aux hivers rudes donc
ça aurait pu être juste d en fait les
amniotes base on aurait pu utiliser la
thermogénèse sans frissons et toux le
mécanisme de cellulaires de la
thermogénèse sans frisson aurait pu
apparaître chez l'ancêtre des amis haute
mais pas forcément pour un métabolisme
en d'autres termes ça aurait pu servir
barbry comme je disais à réchauffer un
organe à se réchauffer mais que pendant
l'hiver ça aurait pu servir un couvent
et d eux ça aurait pu servir à plein de
choses il ya plein d'idées certainement
que j'oublie vous pouvez les rajouter en
commentaire
landau terminé pas la seule explication
en fait on ne cherche pas à établir une
en fait c'est ça le problème de cet
article c'est qu'il va chercher à
établir que tout que tous les amis au d
t en de termes alors qu'en fait on
cherche juste à établir pourquoi
l'ancêtre en commun des amis hôte aurait
eu un mécanisme cellulaire permettant la
thermogénèse sans frissons ce mécanisme
cellulaire de la thermogénèse sans
frisson dans l'absolu il n'a pas à
toucher le corps entier tout au long de
l'année il peut juste affecter une
partie du corps quelques organes pendant
une période de l'année le mécanisme
cellulaire est là et ensuite ce
mécanisme cellulaire aurait évolué chez
les mammifères et les oiseaux pour
donner landau thermique on le reconnaît
donc voilà c'est là où je veux en venir
c'est qu'en fait cet article il part de
ceux de cette observation qui est juste
et qui est la thermogénèse sans frisson
existe chez des mammifères chez les
oiseaux il part de cette hypothèse qui
est valide que la thermogénèse sans
frisson de fait a dû probablement existé
chez l'ancêtre en commun de tout ce
monde là qui est aussi l'ancêtre commun
des amiotte mais là où ils se trompent à
mon avis ou là où il il est incomplet
c'est un pas qu'ils se trompent c'est là
où il est incomplet c'est que il
n'explore qu'une seule hypothèse et
cette hypothèse c'est celle de landau
termine ancestrales alors qu'il ya plein
d'autres hypothèses qui peuvent
expliquer pourquoi mécanismes
cellulaires permettant la thermogénèse
s'enfouissent on aurait pu au apparaître
avant cette thermogénèse sans frisson
n'était pas forcément pour l'un de
terminer à la base elle a peut-être
seulement été cooptés c'était peut-être
une pré adaptation on appelle ça une
réadaptation à halle en doutez remis en
fait mais peut-être que cette
thermogénèse s'enfouissent ont servi à
autre chose
chez les amis auto départ et donc je
pense que c'est l'erreur qui est commise
dans cet article c'est que ils vont
directement dans l'hypothèse de landau
thermie ancestrale en lien avec ce
qu'elle fait l'équipe de seymour avant
qui est de proposer que les crocodiles
étaient ancestralement était
primitivement en d'autres termes il se
dirige droit vers landau terminant
sinistrals
sans considérer d'autres hypothèses et
ça je pense que c'est la plus beau le
plus gros problème de cette hypothèse de
cet article c'est qu'ils ne s'arrêtent
que sur une hypothèse une des multiples
hypothèses pour expliquer cette
observation de base la thermogénèse sans
frisson des oiseaux et des mammifères
voilà donc ça c'est le mécanisme jeu
scroll un peu dans le dans l'article
pour vous montrer il vous montre le
mécanisme cellulaire responsable de la
thermogénèse sans frisson exactement le
même chez les mammifères et les oiseaux
est littéralement un copier coller et
après ils vont à la recherche à la pêche
aux arguments pour dire notamment des
arguments faux cils parce que c'est ça
qui nous intéresse a des arguments chez
les fossiles qui qui vont soutenir que
les ancêtres des amis haute moderne
savoir les synopsis bazzo pour les
mammifères et les sourds ou psy de base
eau pour les reptiles et les oiseaux et
est en d'autres termes et donc ils font
une liste d'arguments qui vont dans leur
sens alors il commence notamment par la
présence de ce qu'on appelle lost phibro
lamellaire dont klaus phibro lamellaire
c'est plus ou moins vous savez quand on
fait une coupe dans l'os soit on observe
des des cercles de croissance
marc et dans ce cas là ça veut dire que
l'animal grandissait par grandisse et
que en été mais qu'en hiver il y avait
un arrêt de croissance soit on constate
que l'os est bien homogène et ça veut
dire que l'animal non seulement ne
n'avais pas d'armé de croissance mais
qu'en plus on n'ose été retravaillé sans
cesse mais ça c'est caractéristique des
andes au terme donc la noce fibre
lamellaire c'est quand cnoss est
complètement bas en d'autres termes
c'est de l'os dando terme quoi donc là
ils prennent ça comme preuve des on a
retrouvé de l'os fibre lamellaire chez
tous les amis hot voilà chez les
dinosaures notamment alors là chez les
archosaures ont d'ailleurs je savais pas
que j'aie les dinosaures h et tous les
arts causant on retrouve de l'os libre
lamellaire oui on en retrouve aussi chez
les crocodiles or les crocodiles sont
ectothermes alors même si à la base il
était en d'autres termes il ne devrait
pas avoir deux fibres lamellaire et on
dans l'absolu re d'entre eux même chez
les amphibiens il ya des amphibiens du
trias qui ont de l'os fibre lamellaire
alors est ce que ça veut dire que les
amphibiens aussi était à 100 est ce que
ça veut dire que les amphibiens aussi
était un sens chaud ou est ce que ça
veut dire
que les est-ce que ça veut dire que l'os
qui brûla mais l'air est pas un très bon
indicateur de métabolisme à sang chaud
bon la réalité c'est que même un animal
qui grandit en milieu tropical ne va pas
avoir de certes de croissance est un
animal qui grandit vite même un animal à
sang froid mais qui grandit vite quand
il est petit va aussi avoir de l'os
fibre lamellaire par exemple le cas des
crocodiles et il ya même des cas de raid
de chez les crocodiles je crois aussi où
on trouve de l'os libre lamellaire dans
certains lots et de l'os avec des belles
cernes de croissance dans certains
autres donc bref love love fibre
lamellaire mais ça ils l'expliquent en
plus ça ils le disent c'est pas vraiment
une un argument qui marche très bien
et je suis d'accord c'est pas un
argument qui marche super bien la
deuxième c'est la deuxième c'est la
hauteur des animaux alors ça c'est un
argument qui est pas banal c'est qu'en
fait la distance qui sépare le coeur du
sommet de la tête sur un animal
actuel ou éteint est directement
proportionnel à la puissance du coeur
donc ça on est d'accord je veux dire le
coeur faut qu'il soit suffisamment
puissant pour envoyer le sang jusqu'à la
tête or la puissance du coeur n'est
limitée chez les ectothermes par le fait
que les expos terme en fait ils ont ils
ont pas de ils ont un coeur qui est
passé par est chez nous les mammifères
on a un coeur qui est bien séparée en
deux on a un système qui va qui va être
connectés uniquement aux poumons et un
système qui va être connecté à tout le
reste du corps un système vasculaire qui
va être connecté à tout le reste du
corps est en fait le système la partie
du coeur qui est connecté au poumon est
plus petite que la partie du coeur qui
est connecté au reste du corps ce qui
fait que il ya plus de pression
dans la partie connecté au corps ce qui
fait qu'il ya suffisamment de pression
pour vous envoyer du sang jusque dans la
tête et jusque dans les pieds et pour
que ce sens qui ensuite soit poussé pour
vous remonter des pieds jusqu'au coeur
donc la partie qui est connecté au corps
est très puissante donc le corps le
coeur est plus gros et la partie qui est
connecté au poumon par contre avec plus
petit parce que les poumons c'est juste
à côté du coeur j'ai tous les chez tous
les tétrapodes les poumons sur à côté du
coeur donc si vous en voyez trop de
pression vous allez tous vous faire
éclater
donc ça ça veut dire qu'en gros chez les
équipes chez les en d'autres termes vous
avez une séparation du coeur qui permet
justement c'est cette pulsion
différentiel cette pression
différentielle entre la partie
systémique et la partie pulmonaire alors
que chez les expos terme là vous avez un
coeur qui est non compartimenté et du
coup la pression est la même partout et
c'est pour ça que la plupart et d'après
ce qu'ils disent c'est pour ça que la
plus que tout les ectothermes en fait
son plat au maillet et ça s'est aussi
connecté du coup à la posture bien que
plus vous avez une posture érigé plus
vous avez plus il va vous falloir de la
puissance cardiaque pour que le sang qui
au bout de vos pieds ici
en fait il va vous falloir de la
pression cardiaque non pas pour
l'envoyer jusqu'aux pieds mais pour
arriver ensuite à le faire remonter pour
que quand ça pousse en fait ça fasse
remonter le sens qu'ils étaient dans les
pieds donc ça c'est déjà la posture
érigé du coup elle serait aussi
directement liés en fait à la pression
du coeur est là donc ce qui l'utilisent
c'est la position la position de la tête
par rapport au coeur parce que la tête
il ya le cerveau et que le cerveau c'est
un organe qui doit être irrigué et donc
cette distance entre la tête et le coeur
elle elle est directement proportionnel
à la puissance de votre coeur et
notamment et cette puissance de votre
coeur ne peut pas être trop puissantes
si vous êtes un ectothermes parce qu'un
ectothermes ne peut pas protéger ses
poumons en ayant à coeur compartimenté
et donc une pression sanguine qui est
différente du côté poumon et du côté du
reste du corps c'est l'hypothèse de base
et donc à partir de là bas il mesure
tout simplement sur des squelettes qui
ont été montés la distance entre
l'endroit où doit se trouver le coeur
c'est à dire généralement juste juste
derrière le sternum donc on va mesurer
cette distance jusqu'à la tête et ça va
vous donner donc ce qu'il dit c'est que
bon chez les petits animaux ça
s'applique pas par contre les grands en
d'autres termes et les grands
ectothermes il va y avoir des
différences et dans un grand en d'autres
termes un grand ectothermes pardon se
rappela voilà alors qu'un grant en
d'autres termes lui pourra avoir une
tête très haute et une posture érigé est
donc fort de cette observation ce qu'ils
nous disent c'est que si vous avez une
certaine distance si vous dépassez une
certaine distance entre le coeur est là
et le haut du corps chez un animal et un
en regardant leurs squelettes et ben
vous devriez pouvoir dire en tout cas si
l'animal était suffisamment grand vous
devriez pouvoir dire si cet animal et
textos terme ou en d'autres termes et en
ce qu'ils ont regardé ils ont regardé
des sauropodes comme par exemple les les
pareil azor ils ont regardé des synapses
hits comme par exemple le mot scops et
ils ont mesuré la distance entre la tête
et le sternum ou en tout cas le bas de
la cage thoracique et donc à chaque fois
ce qu'ils constatent pas c'est
qu'effectivement la tête et super août
chez ces animaux comparé à la position
du coeur
donc ces animaux devaient avoir un coeur
compartimenté et donc il devait être en
d'autres termes
donc ça c'est leur raisonnement là où
leur raisonnement pêche un peu je trouve
c'est que il trahit il trace en fait le
lien entre coeur compartimenté et en
d'autres termes y
avoir un coeur compartimentée
aujourd'hui ça se retrouve effectivement
chez les oiseaux et les mammifères mais
ça veut pas dire que les deux sont liés
c'est une corrélation n'est pas
forcément causalité et en l'occurrence
il y à un contre exemple ah ça c'est que
crocodiles ont un coeur qui est semi
compartimenter les crocodiles ont un
coeur dans lequel il ya une cloison avec
juste un petit trou entre les deux
cloisons donc fonctionnellement il
s'agit d'un choeur non compartimenté
mais physiquement il ya une
compartimentation
et ils peuvent fermer ce trou
occasionnellement permettant une
séparation physique entre la circulation
pulmonaire et la circulation dans le
reste du corps donc ça c'est quand même
un contre argument de poids le lien
tracé entre compartimentation du coeur
et endothermique il est tout sauf
évident même s'il est généralement
accepté soit j'en suis d'accord il est
généralement accepté mais il est tout
sauf évident donc ça c'est le premier
problème le deuxième problème c'est
quand il se met à appliquer ça à des
soro psid comme les ravit soutien et les
synapses hits comme le dit métro donc y
avait une crête est là donc il dit bah
on a des traces sur ses vertèbres que
les organes comme les crêtes et est
irrigué donc pareil la pression sanguine
devait être suffisamment grande pour
envoyer du sang jusque là haut et alors
là le dit métro dont il ya quand même un
mètre cinquante de distance entre le
coeur et le haut de la crête dire qu'il
était très très très en d'autres termes
le dit métro dont ouais mais il ya un
contre exemple encore une fois les
tortues et notamment les tortues géantes
des galapagos les tortues géantes des
galapagos elles font entre 50 cm et 1
mètre de haut donc il ya largement chez
les plus grosses au moins là largement
plus que 58 cm entre le coeur et le haut
de la carapace et le haut de la carapace
il est recouvert d'écaillés qui sont
vivantes donc qui sont irriguées et
c'est pourtant elles sont à sans
froisser ces tortues donc pareil le
raisonnement là une fois plus il est
relativement limitée et il s'agit pas de
petites limites quoi je veux dire c'est
des exceptions qui sont très évidente
dans la nature actuelle donc des choses
qui sont factuellement observable c'est
pas genre d exception qui sont dans le
registre fossile ou il faut admettre que
les amphibiens qui existait au trias
était à sang froid ou à sang chaud
non les tortues des galapagos modernes
sont à sang froid et ont une carapace
qui dont le sommet est situé à plus de
50 cm au dessus de leur coeur
comment on explique ça dans ce cadre là
ça veut surtout dire que l'argument du
coup il a des limites l'argument a des
limites ensuite il parle de la taille
des faux ramène dans l'est dans les
halls ont alors ça ça veut dire qu'en
grohl les oslon pour se renouveler ont
besoin
d'être irrigués les oslon c'est
l'humérus et le fémur typiquement ils
ont besoin d'un training irrigués pour
que le tissu osseux puisse se renouveler
et cette irrigation elles seraient elles
se reflètent dans la taille du trou dans
lequel l'artère rentrer dans l'os
cette la taille de cette artère est
étendue coup différente chez les ans de
terre mais chez les ectothermes les en
d'autres termes ayant la plus grosse
foramen que les ectothermes sauf que
pareil encore une fois il y à des
exceptions et dans ces exceptions il y
aller les arts il ya les warrants donc
les warrants sont des ectothermes qui
font exception à la règle donc encore
une fois il ya une exception évidente à
l'un de ses arguments
la biomécanique
bipèdes donc l'argument de la
biomécanique bipèdes ça veut dire qu'on
peut pas être bipèdes sens et en
d'autres termes même en acceptant cette
ce lien entre la bipédie et le landau
thermie bas ça s'applique qu'aux
dinosaures et à certains mammifères or
les dinosaures et certains mammifères ça
veut pas forcément dire que l'ancêtre
des amis haute qui était totalement
quadrupèdes lui était forcément en
d'autres termes et puis enfin il utilise
les isotopes et alors là les isotopes
par contre là c'est le pire exemple de
cherrie picking de tous de tous les
exemples qu'il utilise donc le tchad
picking c'est quand on sélectionne ses
preuves et alors les isotopes ce qui va
chercher il va nous dire que les
analyses isotopiques c'est à dire la
géochimie des ossements chez certains
fossiles reflète un métabolisme en
d'autres termes la composition osseuse
ne va pas être la même chez les en
d'autres termes que chez les expos terme
et donc il va nous chercher tous les
exemples en fait vous on a retrouvé
me osseuse dando terme chez des animaux
qu'on croyait ectothermes donc par
exemple les mosasaures par exemple les
ichtyosaures par exemple les
plésiosaures
du côté des soeurs oxyde et donc du côté
des synapses il va notamment chercher
certains disent ils aux dons du trias
comme liste rose aux russes par exemple
qui ont effectivement une chimie
isotopique qui évoque des andes au terme
oui mais en négligeant totalement
de parler de tous les dc nous donc du
permien qu'on a testé pour ça et qui eux
ont d'une chimie dans des textos terme
donc une chimie osseuse qui reflète un
métabolisme à sang froid donc là il va
juste chercher l'édition de rente qui
l'arrangent excluant les dix innovantes
qu'il arrange pas et qui sont pourtant
plus ancien et plus masos dans la
phylogénie donc meilleur indicateur de
quel est l état ancestral donc là avec
c'est avec ce la géochimie c'est
complètement du chile picking
les turbines au on en import donc voilà
ça s'est réglé et donc au final il finit
avec cet arbre justement où en rouge
alors vous avez l'éclade dans lesquels
il y à au moins une preuve dans doté
remis même sachant qui prend des preuves
dans de thermique qui sont relativement
relativement peu exigeante on va dire ça
comme ça je veux dire notamment la sfi
libre l'a bel air va suivre lamellaire
c'est une première de thermique est très
très très très peu exigeante bas même en
prenant ça vous voyez qu à la base de
l'arbre ben vous avez des tic tic tic
tic plein dectot terme vous avez quand
même plein de trucs qui ne coche
absolument aucune de ces cases qui sont
% qui sont pourtant très facile à cocher
au mieux il ya un gros doute et comme
j'ai dit comme ces arguments pris un par
un sont tous très ont tous un niveau de
validité assez bas ben voilà c'est pas
satisfaisant personnellement je sais pas
satisfaisant à la limite est par exemple
si on reprend aussi l'exemple de la
crête qui est un sage et pas précisé
mais si on reprend l'exemple de la crète
il aplatit district ce qui est un
amphibien avec une crête dorsale donc
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire que lui aussi
était été en d'autres termes et du coup
ça s'ajoute à la présence de deux fibres
lamellaire chez certains amphibiens et
en a même certains amphibiens et c'est
ce que j'ai mis c'est ce que j'ai mis là
ça vient d'être publiée on avait aussi
des amphibiens on part en antarctique
alors c'est pas nouveau comme
information des amphibiens l'antarctique
d'ailleurs les technos pour deal qui est
un grand groupe d'amphibiens ont
continué à survivre à des latitudes très
très hot donc près justement du cercle
polaire en tarte antarctique quelque
part en australie jusqu au crétacé donc
non seulement il y était mais en plus il
y était bien apparemment et et il y
était depuis longtemps puisque on a
aussi des amphibiens qui vivait en
afrique du sud comme toujours c'est aux
antilles à qui vivait en afrique du sud
au dévonien à l'époque où l'afrique du
sud était aussi très proche du cercle
polaire du cercle polaire antarctique
donc à la limite ça aura été même un
argument que j'aurai beaucoup plus
auquel j'aurais été beaucoup plus
sensible pour tout dire j'aurais été
beaucoup plus sensible s'il nous avait
dit vous voyez on a des amphibiens
depuis tellement longtemps près du
cercle polaire il était forcément à sang
chaud
oui sauf que l'idée d'amphibiens à sang
chaud elle l est le monde est tellement
pas prêt pour une idée d'amphibiens
bazzo à sang chaud que vous voyez dans
son arbre là il les a même pas mis donc
en plus son arbre il a pas de groupes
externes voyez vous avez les sauropodes
à gauche vous avez les synappci la
droite mais il n'a même pas mis deux
groupes externes en fait est là si vous
considérez que les amphibiens sont à
cent fois votre groupe ou externes pas
la condition ancestrale chez les amis
note elle est forcément accra sang-froid
quoi est-ce que je suis convaincu alors
l'idée de nand haute et remis
ancestrales pour tous les amis haute est
révolutionnaire oui
est-ce qu'elle va changer la face du
monde je pense pas parce qu'à mon avis
le niveau de preuve et robin ça
m'étonnerait que cet article donne des
grosses fuites donc moi je suis d'accord
pour dire que le système donc de deux
thermos rennaise sans frisson est
probablement ancestrale en tout cas le
cil la mécanique cellulaire de
thermogénèse la mécanique cellulaire qui
permet la thermogénèse sans frisson est
probablement ce sera pour les amis haute
c'est une hypothèse avec laquelle je
peux être d'accord mais à mon avis il
aurait dû discuter de d'une possible
exaltation d'une possible prêt
habitation près présentation il a mon
avis ce mécanisme cellulaire devait
servir peut-être à autre chose et c'est
une hypothèse que j'aurais voulu voir
discuter dans cet article mais face aux
sons des hypothèses parce que comme je
les dis il ya plein de d'hypothèses pour
lesquelles on pourrait générer un corps
auraient avantage à générer de la
chaleur soit pendant une période courte
soit dans un soin le localiser dans
l'organisme quoi et c'est pas forcément
landau thermique complète et totale de
l'or de l'organisme qui est la meilleure
explication et puis puisqu'on parlait de
dando terne et qu'on en a maintenant
fini avec les mammifères dont on passe
aux autres en d'autres termes c'est à
dire les archosaures les archosaures
avec en premier quetzalcoatlus donc ça y
est la grande description de kenza
comenius a été publié quatre ou cinq
articles dans le journal of vertebrate
paleontology donc c'est comme une
monographie mais coupé en plein morceau
en plat de chapitre ça y est la grande
description du thé rose or géant
quetzalcoatlus a été publiée ici je vous
montre juste le dernier chapitre en fait
de cette grande baie de cette grande
monographie qui est la morphologie
fonctionnel où il discute un peu de
toutes les façons dont kenza qu elle
plus pouvait bouger donc par exemple là
ils établissent que kenza qu avec luce
pouvait voler parce que tout dans
l'anatomie de son bras en fait lui
permettait de battre des ailes les
muscles étaient suffisamment puissants
les articulations était suffisamment
mobile pour lui permettre de battre des
ailes donc quetzalcoatlus volet
apparemment selon eux ce qui s'oppose à
une hypothèse qui avait été proposé que
les kids and co est lui scellé that the
govt rx de roumanie et vivait au sol
exclusivement donc un peu comme des
girafes géante et carnivores quoi
ça s'est contredit du coup dans cet
article ce que ce qu'ils disent aussi
c'est que au lieu de tenir ses jambes de
cette façon sur le côté quand ils
volaient donc au lieu d'avoir les jambes
sur le côté en fait ils les avaient
replié en dessous comme un oiseau donc
c'est ce qui est représentée là
dans la figure b alors ça c'est un truc
qui est intéressant parce que du coup ça
réduit aussi du coup la surface de
l'oeil parce que là on pouvait
s'imaginer qu'il y avait de la peau qui
allait du bout du doigt ici jusqu'au
bout des orteils là mais là si vous avez
lel qui va jusque du bout du doigt ici
jusqu'au bout de la queue à la surface
de l'ale est beaucoup plus petit et ça
ça réduit l'importance la portance et du
coup j'aurais bien voulu voir une
estimation justement de la portance de
l'animal étant donné cette nouvelle
reconstruction mais ils la donnent pas
parce que justement ça aurait pu être un
argument en plus ou en moins en faveur
du fait qu'il volait houblon et puis on
a aussi bien que dans cette série
monographique ils ont nommé une nouvelle
espèce de quetzalcoatl us donc
maintenant il ya deux espèces de
quetzalcoatlus une grande et une petite
haie il y a aussi un autre thé rose or
qui a été qu'ils étaient autrefois
attribuée à quetzalcoatlus mais qui
maintenant est en fait un nouveau genre
à part de quetzalcoatl us vous avez
quetzalcoatlus nord tropiques y est la
grande espèce l'espèce géante la plus
connue vous avez quelques zaïko atlus là
où sony l'a l'espèce plus petit et vous
avez où elle n'obtint russe brevirostris
qui est l'autre espèce qui était
autrefois attribuée à quetzalcoatlus ce
qui est
et qui est maintenant attribuée à un
genre différent donc la petite espèce
est considérée comme une autre espèce
pas comme des juvéniles de quetzalcoatl
us si vous voulez savoir pourquoi faudra
lire les détails parce que je peux pas
j'ai pas tout lu honnêtement chez d'une
je suis pas experte et rose or donc je
suis pas capable de juger vraiment de ce
qui est pertinent en taxonomie des
ptérosaures et de deux ça se joue sur
des détails anatomiques qui sont qui
sont tout à fait évaluables et on a
droit d'accord vous n'êtes pas d'accord
donc si ça vous intéresse allez lien
c'est si vous n'êtes pas les aux
artistes aussi à les lire cet article
qui est très intéressant puisque est
vraiment il propose toutes les clés pour
reconstruire un quetzalcoatlus
anatomiquement correct
par exemple la wii un autre truc
intéressant avec le quetzal coeff de ces
nouvelles reconstruction de quetzalcoatl
us c'est la longueur des jambes les
jambes sont en fait très très long chez
quetzalcoatl même comparé aux bras on
voit toujours le dos chez les kids alcoa
est lui sans fin j'étais aux arts en
général on va toujours le dos qui est
penché comme ça parce que les jambes
sont courtes et les bras sont très
longues quel talent qu elle plus il
avait quand même des très longues jambes
et donc ça ça participe aussi à leur
reconstitution d'un qe2 alcoa plus comme
une cigogne donc qui passait quand même
beaucoup de temps au sol même s'il était
capable de voler donc il reste quand
même plus ou moins en ligne avec cette
hypothèse d'accueil zelko atlus qui
chassait au sol le bec est très très
faim par un manche et quetzalcoatlus
donc ça devait être un généraliste
c'était pas comme un marabout qui a un
énorme bug qui est vraiment un carnivore
stricte quoi peut-être que quelqu'un est
lui c'était carnivores omnivore et il
évalue aussi du coup à la lumière de la
longueur de ses jambes par rapport à la
longueur des bras exil valu les
hypothèses de d'envol donc l'hypothèse
du sceau donc juste il sautait grâce à
leurs longues jambes longues pattes
arrière ils ont été capables de
s'envoler
ou bien l'hypothèse qui a été aussi
développé de la
lancée mais avec les bras a les bras
avant comme certaines chauve souris le
font avec les bras avant ils prennent
une poussée sur les bras et ensuite ils
s'envolent donc il ya aussi cette
hypothèse là qui a été proposé et il y a
aussi le l'hypothèse tout simplement de
la course en tant qu il l'illustré donc
juste il courait et s'envoler en fait
commencé à battre des ailes et finissez
par sembler un peu comme le font
certains canards pas
donc ils discutent les trois hypothèses
et leur conclusion c'est que les trois
ont d'énormes problèmes parce que quel
talent qu as tu lu ce notamment la forme
géante belle île en mer d'un peu toutes
les lois de la physique ça je veux dire
quelle que soit la biologique vous que
vous pensez reconstitué pour qu'ils y
commettent plus de toute façon quelle
que soit l'hypothèse que vous voulez
défendre quel alcoa plus c'est une
anomalie c'est une anomalie il est trop
grand il est juste trop grand donc ils
emmerdent des lois de la physique et
s'ils étaient réellement capable de
voler ben oui donc clairement beaucoup
de sa pose beaucoup de problèmes en tout
cas aux gens qui essaye de reconstituer
son mode de vie bon voila si ça vous
intéresse je vous invite à aller lire
tous ces articles
il y en a quatre ou cinq j'ai pas eu le
temps de tous les lire je n'ai pas la
compétence de toute façon pour les
évaluer de façon critique je peux vous
dire ce qui a été proposé on reste dans
les archosaures avec maintenant un
nouvel an qu'ils osent hors d'amérique
du sud vous en avez forcément entendu
parler c'est la nouvelle star des
réseaux sociaux sté gaujos avec sa
massue voyez en forme de alors ils
disent que ça ressemble à une arme
aztèque
jolie coïncidence de l'histoire j'ai
envie de dire ce qu'il ya d'intéressant
avec ceux testés gouro ce n'est pas
tellement la massue qu'il a au bout de
la queue c'est le fait que c'est un an
qu'ils osent hors du de l'hémisphère sud
et comme je voulais aider dans une
prison une précédente vidéo ça court pas
les rues les ankylose or dans
l'hémisphère sud en réalité il y en a
très très peu on a beaucoup de
stégosaure enfin des jolies exemple de
stégosaure dans l'hémisphère sud mais on
n'a pas beaucoup dans closer donc c'est
toujours une grande nouvelle dans
accueillir deux nouveaux
essais ankylose en plus le il est
tellement complet qu'en fait ils ont pu
faire une réévaluation de la phylogénie
des ankylose orient afin d'étirer au
fort en général et ce qu'ils trouvent et
bien c'est que ce set ankylose or avec
d'autres espèces notamment d'antarctique
et de l'hémisphère sud forment un
nouveau clad qui vient se nicher en fait
entre les eaux qu'il entre les no 2 or
et les stégosaures vous voyez vous avez
la succession stégosaure no2 or ankylose
or il n'est donc en kilos d'or au sens
strict j'ai envie de dire et entre les
stégosaures lnd aux origines et ben vous
avez ce nouveau cloud ankylose or qu'ils
ont appelé les parents qu'ils osent or
voilà donc à côté des antilles losange
littéralement donc bref il y aurait une
dispersion dans le gondwana à un moment
d en philosophe ou voir même une origine
seconde doyenne pourquoi pas puisque le
lent qu'il ose leur supposée africains
dont j'avais parlé la dernière fois
était aussi le plus ancien puisqu'il
date et du du jurassique en tout cas ce
qu'il ya d'intéressant par rapport à ça
que c'est pas tellement la morphologie
de sa queue on s'en fiche un peu la
morphologie qui là je veux dire c'est un
an qu'ils osent or c'est normal qu'ils
aient des trucs au bout de la queue
je viens les stégosaures ont des épines
sur leur que les ankylose or monsieur au
bout de l'heure que donc c'est normal
que ce teggour hausse et une arme au
bout de sa queue dans la grande question
du coup maintenant c'est les stégosaures
ils ont des pointes au bout de la queue
les ankylose aussi cet égout rosso ci
alors pourquoi les deux auri des oeufs
dans don non pas vous avez deux heures
pourquoi les no 2 or ide ont perdu le
match au bout de l'heure que ça c'est ça
c'est une question intéressante plus que
de se demander d'où vient la morphologie
de la queue de seguros c'est de se
demander pourquoi les no 2 au rider ont
perdu la leur donc voilà une petite
découverte intéressante et qui est
d'autant plus intéressant que j'étais
gosse est quasiment complet non
seulement c'est pas souvent qu'on en
trouve mais alors des complets je vous
en parle même pas on reste en amérique
du sud avec maintenant on va changer on
va sortir un petit peu de la
paléontologie mais plus on va rentrer un
peu dans la politique qui entoure la
paléontologie a notamment la politique
de l'export des fossiles en dehors des
pays considérés comme en voie de
développement
donc ici il s'agit notamment du brésil
et du fameux ubi djarrah donc ubi
djarrah dont je n'avais pas parlé dans
un palais aux news qui était un nouveau
été rose or as darquy des gens n'avaient
pas parlé dans pas les odieuses tout
simplement parce qu'il y avait un énorme
scandale autour du bide jaraëb ijarah a
été exporté de façon illégale il a été
exporté du brésil de façon illégale il a
été acheté au brésil exporté de façon
illégale est acheté à un collectionneur
par un musée ensuite donc qui a acquis
du matériel absolument illégal donc j'en
avais pas parlé de cette subite jara
parce que comme un peu pour l'angle
birmans en fait lambres birman j'ai
arrêté aussi de parler des découvertes
qui ont été faites dans l'ombre birman
parce que c'est éthiquement ça se fait
pas voilà et donc il ya d'autres trucs
un très connu qui viennent qui ont été
exportés comme ça il également du brésil
irrite à tort qui est maintenant en
allemagne irrite à tort le fameux
le fameux spinosaures a aussi été
exportées apparemment illégalement dont
il ya plein de trucs qui viennent du
crétacé du brésil qui sont illégaux
essentiellement dans des musées dans des
musées allemands apparemment mais bon il
est pas impossible en fouillant les
fonds de tiroirs qu'on retrouve aussi
par chez nous c'est pas un problème
enfin par chez nous en france je deviens
donc ça et ça c'est un énorme problème
en tout cas pour les auteurs de cet
article qui sont de résilience je crois
que c'est juan cisneros le principal
auteur si ce n'est le seul auteur voilà
juan cisneros paléontologues brésiliens
qui a fait ses études en afrique du sud
ce qu'on a c'est qu'elle va il détaille
de toutes les raisons pour lesquelles il
faut pas faux pas exporter des fossiles
comme ça il également ça se fait pas ça
se fait pas pourquoi ça se fait pas
parce que après les exporter d'une part
vous vous financer un marché noir le
marché noir ça ça ne génère rien de bon
voilà donc vous financez le marché noir
et ensuite vous débarrasser un pays d'un
fossile qui lui appartient et ça ça a
des conséquences sur la recherche locale
parce que c'est des faux cils importants
qui se retrouvent à l'étranger et les
pays en voie de développement n'ont pas
les moyens d'envoyer leurs chercheurs à
l'étranger donc en fait vous empêchez
les chercheurs locaux d'étudier les
fossiles de leur pays en faisant ça
physiquement je veux dire alors en
théorie oui on peut toujours voyagé mais
en pratique les pays en voie de
développement n'ont pas toujours
suffisamment d'argent à injecter dans la
recherche pour que leurs chercheurs
puissent se promener aller voir leur
propre fossiles ailleurs donc ça c'est
ça fait partie des multiples problèmes
éthiques qui sont liées à sa
et sas a rejoint un autre article qui a
aussi été publiée qui est du coup sûr
les fausses moby aliens voilà les
fameuses fausse momie alien comme j'ai
déjà j'en ai déjà parlé plein de fois
dont je vais pas m'arrêter trop
longtemps dessus attaques liées à cette
espèce de d'embryons voilà qui a été
pris pour un peu un embryon
d'extraterrestres alors que c'est un
embryon humain maintenant ça a été
prouvé par des analyses génétiques et
puis les fameuses nomine nascar qui ont
toujours été reconnus comme des momies
humaine donc c'est pas un article de des
bagages ainsi un article qui dénoncent
la fraude en disant que c'est
inadmissible qu'il faut arrêter de
soutenir des
faut arrêter de soutenir des initiatives
comme ça c'est pas de la vraie recherche
qui est conduite c'est juste du pillage
et du sabotage de
delà du patrimoine
sud américains et des pays en voie de
développement en général là on s'arrête
sur l'amérique du sud parce que c'est
eux qui ont publié cette semaine enfin
ce mois ci mais en réalité c'est du
sabotage qui a lieu constamment tout le
temps avec des complicités dans le
marché noir donc à chaque fois c'est
pareil
n'achetez pas une momie en vous disant
je vais la sauver achetez achetez un
restes archéologiques au marché noir en
s'imaginant qu'on est en train de le
sauver c'est une illusion vous êtes en
train de financer le marché noir en
faisant ça acheter un fossile en vous
disant il sera mieux chez moi sur mon
étagère que dans les caves d'un musée
dans un pays en voie de développement
c'est pareil c'est une illusion faut
arrêter
faut arrêter votre fossiles il va être
safe sur son étagère tant qu'il sera
chez vous une fois que vous serez mort
il partira à la poubelle il partira aux
enchères il partira dans un vide
greniers mais il sera perdu voilà donc
non et de toute façon les fossiles sont
pas forcément plus sèche il ya un truc
la dernière fois qu'il m'a fait bondir
c'est quand j'ai entendu des gens dire
ah ouais mais ils sont mieux chez nous
chez eux parce que chez eux de façon les
musées y brûle en référence je crois que
c'est le musée de rio qui avait cramé
mais bref il ya un musée qui a cramé il
n'ya pas longtemps en brûlant plusieurs
le type effectivement donc il ya du
matériel qui a été perdu et du coup les
gens utilisaient ça pour justifier le
fait qu'on se serve au marché noir et
qu'on exporte des fossiles de ces pays
là parce qu'ils prennent pas soin de
leurs fossiles vous voyez il est cramé
leurs musées et latin il a tu la gardes
tu fais notre dame de paris
ben vers nous aussi on fait cramer notre
patrimoine d'hier les accidents ça
arrive voilà c'est ça n'arrive pas
qu'aux autres mais ça n'arrive pas
qu'aux pays en voie de développement
donc il faut faut arrêter avec cette
mentalité là c'est dénoncer ici et je
suis tout à fait d'accord avec le com du
colonialisme c'est de l'impérialisme du
col y aller demain p ça comme vous
voulez c'est du néocolonialisme parce
que maintenant il les paye voilà ils
payent le
matériel patrimoniale qu'ils exportent
les gens qui font ça alors qu'avant
comme c'était coloniale c'est juste il
se servait un point c'est tout veut pas
d'argent donné en échange mais voilà
donc on peut appeler ça du
néocolonialisme mais quoi qu'il arrive
c'est une mentalité coloniale de croire
qu'un occidental peut croire se servir
comme ça dans un pays étranger en se
disant je ferai mieux que ça c'est bon
ça c'est pas c'est moralement
complètement et éthiquement complètement
pété voilà et il faut arrêter et je suis
d'accord avec eux et donc ces
nominations sont pas des banques et
spécialement dans cet article parce que
selon eux tous on n'y a rien à débloquer
on voit très bien que c'est des momies
humaine qui ont été mutilés et notamment
quand la dia tomite s'en va parce que
cette date au mythe la poudre blanche
qui les recouvre elle et elle est très
fine et elle s'en va très facilement
parce qu'elle n'est pas d'époque la
concept dia tommy de s'en va on voit
qu'il ya des impressions du tissu de la
momie originel sur la peau donc que le
tissu a été enlevée donc la momie a été
débarrassée de ses effets donc de son
contexte archéologique donc déjà ça
c'est inadmissible donc les gens qui
prétendent faire de la science en
achetant ces momies sont forcément au
courant de ça et sont forcément en tort
c'est il faut arrêter de le faire un
point c'est tout il faut arrêter de
soutenir ces gens là surtout on peut se
laver les mains en se disant moi c'est
bon j'ai jamais acheter un truc mais non
faut aussi arrêter de soutenir ce genre
d'initiative et puis pour finir avec les
faux cils exportés illégalement du
brésil tétrapodes office tetra peau de
fils donc le serpent à quatre pattes
littéralement alors c'est pas
complètement sûr que tétrapodes office
et été exportés illégalement du brésil
en réalité c'est un c'est encore en
discussion on va dire en tout cas il ya
suspicion de marché noir mais voyez ça
souligne un truc cet article il est
intéressant parce qu'il souligne un truc
si vous voyez tous les auteurs qui ont
travaillé sur des travaux d'office dans
cet article en a pas un seul qui vient
du brésil ça fait partie des choses que
justement cisneros à signaler dans son
article article que j'ai pas dit mais
qui est sorti dans mail or si je ne
m'abuse voilà netscher écologie
évolution
donc oui juan cisneros a souligné que
jamais ou quasiment jamais les
chercheurs locaux ne sont inclus dans
les recherches sur les fossiles du
brésil donc et là c'est encore un
exemple assez criant puisque là il ya
aucun de ces chercheurs qui est
réellement affilié à une astuce une
institution brésilienne voilà la liste
des institutions
aucun d'entre eux n'est au brésil donc
ça ça fait aussi partie des choses que
roanne cisneros à souligner c'est que
bah ouais non seulement les fossiles
s'en vont mais en plus du coup les
chercheurs locaux n'en profite pas donc
bref tétrapodes office on lâche la
politique et on revient de la science
des drapeaux de fixer ce fossile donc ce
fossile qui consiste en une empreinte et
une contre emprunte ici vous voyez le
corps très très long et ici vous avez
les petites pattes la voyez les petites
pattes avant qu'ils sont là les petites
pattes arrières qui sont là et le crâne
qui se trouve sur la contre emprunte ici
et qui est en empreinte de ce côté-là
tétrapodes office c'est donc un corps de
serpent envoyé un très long corps de
serpent enfin très long à l'échelle de
l'animal voyez j'aime beaucoup cette
photo parce que là vous voyez le doigt
il vous donne vraiment l'échelle c'est
vraiment tout petit et trapu d'office et
si tout mignon ça va être trop chou peut
y avoir peut-être un peu difficile et
donc c'est donc un long corps de serpent
avec des petites pattes de lézard voilà
des petites pattes relictuelle de lézard
donc il correspond littéralement à ce
qu'on s'attendrait à voir ce qu'on
s'attendrait d'un chaînon manquant voilà
employons terme un intermédiaire entre
un animal qui se dirige vers une
morphologie serpentiforme est un ancêtre
de morphologie reptilienne plus
classique donc un serpent à quatre
pattes tétrapodes office donc ce
tétrapodes office c'est un fossile
important du coup vu qu'il a été supposé
il a déjà été étudié par le passé et à
l'époque et bien il en avait conclu que
c'était un serpent à quatre pattes
injustement comme je disais ce fameux
chaînon manquant et dans cette étude eh
bien les ses auteurs ici caldwell et ses
collègues nous disent qu'en fait non
tetra peut d'office n'est pas n'est pas
un serpent tout cas n'est pas un ancêtre
des serpents mais il appartiendrait à
une famille proche des reptiles mozart
qu'on appelle les dolly cause or donc
les mosasaures ce sont des reptiles
aquatiques du delà du crétacé des
warrants aquatiques en fait les dolly
cause or sont plus ou moins inclus parmi
les mozart disons pour faire simple je
vais appeler ça des mots à tort même si
s'est débattue et en fait donc
tétrapodes office ne serait finalement
qu'un
qu'un petit reptile aquatique du crétacé
on va dire que la morphologie
serpentiforme irait bien avec un mode de
vie aquatique salle l'aiderait à onduler
à nager et puis sa ressemblance
superficielles avec un serpent viendrait
du fait que les mosasaures sont compris
comme étant d intenses ont interprété du
moins comme étant des proches parents
des serpents mais ce ne sont pas des
serpents oiseaux
donc ça exclurait en fait d'être à pau
deux fils de sa position de chaînon
manquant entre les serpents et les
reptiles à morphologie plus plus banal
on va dire alors quelles sont les
caractéristiques qui font de t'être un
peu d'office un long serpent alors dans
ses caractéristiques il y a très
intéressant et très important
l'assertion détend donc les dents chez
les serpents
alors sont techniquement interprété
comme ayant une racine mais en réalité
la racine est très petit et alors elles
sont techniquement à interpréter comme
ayant des racines ça veut dire
exactement ce que ça veut dire c'est à
dire que techniquement oui y ait une
racine enfin on la voit pas super bien
quoi voyez que là c'est par exemple vous
avez dans le serpent là dedans elle est
plus posé sur la mâchoire qu'elle n'est
réellement implanté dans la mâchoire et
nous les mammifères on a ce qu'on
appelle la condition tecau d'hondt avec
des grosses racines qui s'implantent
réellement dans la mâchoire et en fait
des travaux d'office il a cette
morphologie avec des grosses racines qui
s'implantent dans la mâchoire donc ici
représentée en le et qu'on voit ici sur
le spécimen réel donc il a des grosses
racines qui s'implantent dans des
alvéoles dans la mâchoire ça ça se
retrouve chez les mammifères ça se
retrouve chez les dinosaures et ça se
retrouve chez les mozart et les serpents
comme je les dis sont techniquement
tecau dont tu donc techniquement ils ont
du tissu qui peut être interprété comme
du tissu racinaire mais c'est pas aussi
évident que chez les mozart c'est là ça
ressemble vraiment à la condition shy'm
zaz a envoyé voyez la couronne ici et
voyez la racine là avec la levée au lit
si je veux remettre à mozac d'or voilà
ça c'est une danse typique de mozart
couronne racines en plus la racine lé
conflit est exactement comme sur le
com / tétrapodes fils donc déjà ça le
premier truc qu'ils excluent des
serpents c'est ça le deuxième truc qui
n'exclut des serpents aussi c'est c'est
la morphologie des vertèbres les
vertèbres des serpents ont deux
articulations et alors que les alors que
les autres animaux généralement donc une
seule articulation entre les vertèbres
donc en fait les werther où elles sont
articulés comme ça avec de paix avec une
paire d'articulation et puis elle peut
bouger comme ça donc j'ai vu dessus ça
fait comme ça et comme ça voilà bon
jeremy teela de bouche sont tous comme
ça
mais en tout cas voilà ça c'est le
normes l'articulation normal des
vertèbres chez un
pilote classique et donc les serpents ce
qu'ils ont en fait c'est qu'ils ont deux
jeux de d'articulation donc un premier
jeu d'articulation comme ça et un
deuxième jeu d'articulation comme ça et
donc ça ça leur donne vraiment une
morphologie de vertèbres très très peu
orthodoxe
on va dire qui est très très rare
généralement chez les êtres vivants il
ya que quelques animaux qui ont ça chez
laisse à penser présent chez tetra peut
d'office apparemment d'après cette étude
ça ne l'est pas donc ça c'est le
deuxième caractère qu'il exclut les
serpents et maintenant qu'est ce qui le
rapproche des mots adore et bien c'est
essentiellement la morphologie de
l'articulation entre le crâne au niveau
de l'oreille et la mâchoire qui est fait
par un os qui s'appelle le carré chez
les serpents vous avez l'ins carré ici
en bleu qui est très allongé alors que
chez tetra peau d'office vous avez un
oscar et qui est nu allongé ni carré
mais qui est en réalité en forme de
disque et ça c'est vraiment très typique
des mozart et donc ça c'est le caractère
principal qui rapproche peut-être un peu
de fils des mots zaza donc quand ils
font tourner d analyse phylogénétique de
diverses façons alors ils utilisent du
bail et bien il utilise du maximum de
parcimonie il utilise plusieurs
il utilise plusieurs matrice aussi à
chaque fois il retrouve est râpeux deux
fils parmi les mosasaures non loin dé
d'olic aux orres plus ou moins loin des
d'olic aux orres en fonction des
analyses c'est plus ou moins fortement
soutenue dans les analyses là vous avez
par exemple un soutien de 100% de
l'inclusion de tétrapodes office parmi
les mozart sur cette analyse bayésienne
donc voilà c'est quand même assez bien
c'est quand même assez bien soutenu dans
certaines analyses qui sont plus
faiblarde que d'autres mais dans
l'ensemble il ya un signal très cohérent
que tétrapodes office n'est pas le
chaînon manquant qu'on croyait qu'il
était entre les serpents et les lézards
de morphologie plus plus ordinaire du
coup ça nous enlève quand même à un
maillon important dans notre
compréhension de l'évolution des
serpents mais faut pas oublier que quand
même d'être un peu de fils malgré tout
ça reste un animal qui est à mi chemin
entre une morphologie serpentiforme et
une morphologie de lézard donc ça reste
quand même un fossile important qui nous
montre comment on passe de l'une à
l'autre comment on passe d'une
morphologie de lézards classique à une
morphologie plus appentis forme donc ça
reste quand même un jalon important ça
reste un fossile important dans notre
compréhension de l'évolution des
reptiles et notamment des reptiles un
forme de serpent sachant qu'il y a pas
que les serpents évidemment qu'ils ont
cette forme allongée avec beaucoup de
vertèbres et des bras et des jambes
réduit il y en a pleins il ya les amphis
ce bénin par exemple je suis plus
convaincu par cette interprétation en
tant que noah sort
que l'interprétation donc serpent donc
je pense qu'on peut on peut s'y fier à
mon avis et c'est cette réinterprétation
en tant que moa or je pense qu'elle va
rester je pense qu'elle va rester dans
la littérature et la dernière petite
curiosité c'est laid et xénon bottes les
xénon bottes à lacets les xénon botte
c'est un genre de de nanorobots je suis
j'ai bien compris qui est fait à partir
de cellules de grenouilles et donc ces
nano robots à partir de cellules de
grenouilles on peut re programmer leur
adn pour qu'il n'ait plus qu'une seule
fonction c'est s'agglutiner se
reproduire c'est des petits amas de
cellules de grenouilles construit
assembler ensemble
reprogrammé dont l'adn a été reprogrammé
et on les plonge dans une solution où il
ya d'autres cellules est en fait leur
but c'est une leçon programmée que pour
se reproduire c'est à dire que eelv ont
agglutiné d'autres cellules c'est ce qui
est représentée là toutes les cellules
envers vous avez de votre xénon bottes
et en fait ils vont agglutinés d'autres
cellules jusqu'à ce que sa forme à
nouveau xénon bottes et ce xénophobe va
lui aussi se mettre à un but signé des
cellules pour former un nouveau vélo
bottes et ainsi de suite
c'est le plus proche qu'on puisse être
d'une de la création d'une forme de vie
en laboratoire
je pense le problème c'est que c'est
déjà fait à partir de cellules vivantes
vu que c'est fait à partir de celle de
grenouilles donc ce n'est pas vraiment
une création de devis en laboratoire
mais c'est le plus proche qu'on puisse
être pour l'instant de la création d'une
forme de vie autonome en laboratoire est
aussi intéressant c'est que comme ils
les ont programmées uniquement à se
reproduire et à rien d'autre en fait
très rapidement ce qu'ils ont constaté
c'est que les le temps de génération
entre les l'exe nos bottes devenait de
plus en plus courts et que et que cela
était permis par le fait en fait que les
xénon bottes devenait de plus en plus
petits donc en fait ils s'agglutinent
est de génération en génération il
agglutinaient de moins en moins de
cellules pour pouvoir se reproduire de
plus en plus vite et ça c'est super
intéressant parce que ça veut dire
qu'ils évoluent et en fait à partir du
moment où on leur a imposé de se
reproduire en fait pas immédiatement il
ya eu sélection naturelle pour des xénon
bottes qui se reproduisait plus vite et
donc c'est l'évolution en direct
reproduit en laboratoire
ni plus ni moins voilà et ça je trouve
ça super intéressant évidemment je vous
fais la version ultra simplifié je
comprends à peine la technologie d xénon
bottes je n'ai aucune idée de comment ça
fonctionne
je trouvais juste hyper intéressant de
mentionner que ça ça existait parce que
quand même c'est quand même vachement
beau d'arriver à reproduire l'évolution
comme ça dans des petites boîtes de
pétri voilà c'était paléo news je vous
remercie de l'avoir suivi n'oubliez pas
de vous abonner pour ne rien manquer
d'anciens bonnes fêtes de fin d'année et
à très bientôt
[Musique]